Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz heute Mittag
und aus Berlin ist mir zugeschaltet der
Politikwissenschaftler Albrecht von
Lucke zweite sommerpressekonferenz des
Bundeskanzlers wir haben sie ihn heute
gesehen
naja wie man ihn kennt gelassen das ist
ja Olaf Scholz Versuch eine gar nicht
gelassene Situation und eine gar nicht
gelassene Stimmung in der Bevölkerung
ein Stück weit würde ich sagen zu
überspielen und es ist bloß heute
besonders deutlich geworden dass diese
gepanz ergibt sich ja quasi immer das
leistungszeugnis eins eben nicht sehr
viel zu tun hat mit der Realität in der
Bevölkerung wo die Werte sowohl der
Ampel aber auch vor allem der SPD
ziemlich im Singflug sind während die
AFD durch die Decke geht also er hat
viel versprochen gerade auch die
Halbierung der AFD und man wird sehen ob
er es einlösen kann klingt so fast als
hätten wir das ein bisschen abgesprochen
wie passen Inhalte und Erzählung von
Scholz zusammen wenig wäre jetzt ihre
Antwort darauf die Frage ist und das
bringt uns ja quasi zur allgemeinfrage
dieser Ampel wie will diese Ampel
eigentlich aus diesem Kommunikation
Desaster rauskommen dass sie dies und
das veranstaltet das Wochen braucht und
am Ende doch nur etwas wahrgenommen wird
das handwerklich nicht ganz sauber ist
ja absolut das ist das Kardinalproblem
also gerade wenn er diese positive
Leistungsbilanz an der ja einiges auch
richtig ist dass die Ampel und gut durch
den Winter gebracht hat das stimmt aber
wenn man sich bewusst macht was dann
davon bleibt dann ist es eine ungeheure
Kakophonie vor allem eigentlich beginnt
mit diesem früher mit einer
heizungsgesetzgebung die an Desaster war
und die maßgeblich davon abhängt dass
der Kanzler viel zu lange eine FDP die
renitent
Opposition in der Regierung spielt die
die Grünen mittlerweile regelrecht an
die Wand gedrückt hat dass der Kanzler
aber diese Kakophonie hat laufen lassen
ein Gesetz das eigentlich über 5 Monate
im Zuge des immer wieder die
Kellnerinnen Streit dann am Schluss
übrigens auch vom
Bundesverfassungsgericht im Sinne des
Smartphones gecancelt wurde weil man
sagte wir hatten ja noch gar keine erste
Lesung wenn das so läuft und der kannst
da so weiter macht es schleifen lässt
und nicht auch einmal dafür sorgt das
Gesetze von Anfang an in Eintracht
kooperativ wie man sich eine Koalition
vorstellt zustande kommt dann glaube ich
wird es mit dieser Koalition kein gutes
Ende nehmen mehr oder weniger ist ja die
Halbzeit für diese Ampel in Sichtweite
und tatsächlich und sie skizzieren das
ja gerade von Lucke fragt man sich am
Anfang waren wir etwas ungnätig
vielleicht mit Müttern Scholz aber jetzt
muss man sich schon fragen wo ist die
Führung bei diesem das ist das große
Problem ich sag's mal pontiert die Krise
ist mittlerweile voll beim Kanzler
angekommen er glaubte ja lange Zeit
selber er könne sich regelrecht
rauslassen im Sinne des schlicht das
oder sagen wir es mal der höheren Gewalt
über den beiden Streithähnen würde er
noch an Reputation gewinnen wenn er denn
nur Grüne und FDP sich lange bekriegen
lasse käme heraus als die große überall
im Stehen die Figur das Gegenteil ist
der Fall wir merken es in der
Bevölkerung seine eigenen Werte sind
schlecht und insofern glaube ich kann
man nur hoffen auch wirklich im Sinne
des Respekts für unsere Demokratie das
ist ja immer das Wort was Urlaub bemüht
dass er sieht wie dramatisch
mittlerweile die Krise in der Regierung
angekommen ist und dass er vor allem
gefordert ist ohne eine klare Führung
wird es mit dieser Koalition nicht
besser werden im Gegenteil ich glaube
die Kakophonie wird sich fortsetzen und
es droht eben auch weil die Position bei
cdu/csu die klassische Opposition so
schwaches es droht dass die AFD dann
immer weiter wächst und auch diese Frage
nach der AFD hatte ja im Grunde genommen
mit einer Erzählung beantwortet und nur
auf Nachfrage ist er darauf eingegangen
ein Schlusspunkt noch mit Blick auf
diesen politischen Herbst also das GEG
wird dann sozusagen in seine dritte
Lesung im Bundestag gehen und abgestimmt
werden aber die nächsten konflikte sind
schon quasi erkennbar am Horizont unter
anderem die Kinder Grundsicherung wird
es dann sozusagen reichen wenn man sich
gegenseitig wieder Briefe schreibt und
die im Nachgang auf Twitter
veröffentlicht nein gar nicht das ist ja
ein Teil des Desasters und man muss es
auf den Punkt bringen solange die FDP
und da hat auch übrigens der Kanzler
wenig Möglichkeiten es sich zum Prinzip
gemacht hat gewissermaßen im Sinne des
Schwanz ist der mit dem Hund wählt immer
Kritik zu üben und der Kanzler nicht
früher agiert und sagt wir müssen uns
beispielsweise mit den starken Figuren
Lindner habe ich und natürlich Olaf
Scholz frühzeitig zusammensetzen eine
klare Linie finden und nicht immer
gegeneinander spielen solange das nicht
der Fall ist wird es schwierig und sehe
ich ziemlich düstere Wolken am Lande und
auch für diese Koalition aufziehen und
das ist meinem Eindruck nach das Problem
die Koalition hängt in Gänze ein Stück
weit vom gut will die schwächsten
Partner
ganz herzlichen Dank für diese
Einschätzung heute hier bei Phoenix
Albrecht von Politikwissenschaftler
Grüße nach Berlin ich danke Ihnen